-Hello, everyone.
Welcome back.
I hope you had a good break.
My name is Janet
Rich-Edwards and I
am one of the two science
advisers to the Radcliffe
Institute here.
And I want to welcome
you back for what
was a great start to
the program in a really
interesting second panel
now focused on solutions.
I'm going to introduce
Anula Jayasuriya, right?
Very good.
Who is the co-founder of
Evolvence India Life Science
Fund, founder of
Exclaim Capital,
and I think possesses more
Harvard degrees than anyone
I've ever met.
She's going to lead us off
and moderate the second panel.
So, welcome.
-Thank you.
Thank you everyone
for being here.
I'm especially delighted
to see so many young women.
And we are all hoping
that we'll be talking
about is relevant for you.
In case you missed
the first panel,
let me just go over
the outline here--
is that I will speak
for a very short time,
each panelist will have
15 minutes to describe
their vantage point,
and then there
will be a Q&A for 15
minutes afterwards.
Please line up and state your
name and your affiliation
when you ask your questions.
So thank you for
panel number one
for giving us a teaser
into panel number two
as we discuss solutions.
And let me also first
thank Nancy Hopkins, who
is the first person who
taught me about transposons
and jumping genes
when I was in college.
I was a Radcliffe alumni.
And then I read
the issue of nature
from 2013 where that
describes her struggle
to bring light to this topic.
And today I'm delighted
to actually see her again
in person.
Thank you, Nancy.
And Harvard and
Radcliffe Institute,
thank you for having me here.
Deborah gave us a suggestion
that I want to emphasize.
Start practicing.
Don't wait to be asked.
Ask to go to the prom.
Invite the person to go
to the prom with you.
Don't wait to ask to be married,
ask the person to marry you.
Good practice.
Ask.
And when you ask, expect to
see some people very surprised
and not necessarily very happy,
but be resilient and stay
to the point.
I'd also want to talk
a little bit about what
Allison talked about.
I brought a series of
articles and among them
was the venture investors
prefer to fund handsome men.
Maybe it was
apocryphal, but there
was a follow up that said
that beautiful women were
the least likely to get funded.
And so that was another part
that was quite interesting.
Then I have an
economist article that's
talking about the weaker sex and
they're not referring to women.
They're talking about
boys and education.
So the pipeline for
high achieving men,
or for men at the school
level is problematic, right?
And it's quite the opposite
in women in college
and in higher education.
So that is also an
ecosystem aspect
that we have to think about.
Now let's talk about boards.
So again, this panel will
talk about it in more detail.
But I think getting on
board is very important.
Debra talked about
the two people.
[? Helena ?] Morrissey, from the
financial services in Britain
is a very interesting woman.
She has taken a
different point of view.
You may all know about
boards in Europe,
where the Nordic countries have
required a certain number quota
system.
And she has taken a
different point of view.
She's calling it the 30% club.
And she sees 30% of
board leadership women
as being the critical number.
I don't know where she pull
that number out, but that is--
And her strategy is
to go to powerful men
in Britain, who are chair people
or chairmen of their boards.
And make them recruit
the women onto the board.
So she's taking a softer
sell, if you will,
rather than the quota system.
I hesi-- I'm of two minds about
mentioning this, which she does
happen to have nine children.
And she is very successful.
That does astound me.
Then another headline
here, female VCs,
what do entrepreneurs
really think?
So this data
suggests-- and it all
comes from the power
of perception--
that men and women
entrepreneurs often think
that male VCs have more power.
So they prefer to be
funded by male VCs
based on this belief in power.
And there is [INAUDIBLE] that
which is also that less than 5%
of venture
capitalists are women.
And I think lots of
data on social behavior
where you like what's like you.
And so it's also harder
for women entrepreneurs
to raise money.
Perhaps some part
of it has to do
with it being that
it's primarily
men making the decision.
Also something that I
think about a whole lot
is that it is hard for women
who are climb being the venture
capital ladder, which is a
delicate ladder for women.
To espouse women,
because there's
a complex dynamic of are
you espousing these women,
because you're a
woman or do you really
believe in their company?
So there are all
kinds of subtleties
that one should think about.
And this article-- we just
know this-- women are not
making progress in the
male dominated VC world
as data show.
So right there is a
pretty pervasive bias
for entrepreneurship, because
the eye of the person who's
making the judgment.
And that brings me to the
unconscious bias world,
which we will hear about here.
And that is that if the system
is geared towards measuring
one group of people
at their talents,
it is fairly
unlikely to work just
as well in another group that
has different characteristics.
And that brings me
to the economist
article from January
23rd this year,
What's holding women back?
So this study showed that
majority of Americans
said that they thought men and
women were equally capable.
However, and so they believed
in meritocracy, democracy,
equality, all those
wonderful things.
However, PS, when
it came to being
asked would you
have a woman lead,
they're using the
word viscerally.
Viscerally, Americans resisted
letting femininity and power
go hand in hand.
And that conclusion was
in our minds, we are open,
but at a gut level,
which is what
unconscious bias taps
into, this is a very hard
to leap for people to make.
And then there's the aspect
of various corporations making
statements, bold statements.
For example, Intel has
appointed Renee James
and given her a
$300 million budget
to increase corporate
diversity, a lot
of it being amongst women.
Now I live in Silicon Valley and
there is a lot of talk in tech,
not in biotech, in tech,
about getting more women
and there are bloggers who are
talking about it all the time.
People judging companies
by their lack of women.
A big spotlight.
I may be just unaware,
but I don't believe quite
that level of focus has
been devoted to biotech.
Perhaps it's because there
are more biotech CEOs and more
senior women in
biotech, but that
doesn't mean that
harsh light shouldn't
be focused on the issue.
So I think it would be
good to do something
that Nancy Hopkins tried to
do and should carry the baton.
And actually talk,
blog, talk about this,
let people hear the
dissatisfaction with the status
quo.
And suggestions might be
to give CEOs incentives
for recruiting women to board.
So recruiting women
in their companies.
There could be other ways to
make this more interesting.
And I'd also share with
you this is an n of 1--
I was trained as a scientist,
but I'm now a business person
so I can use n of
1-- a woman who
had been at Genentech
and at the FDA
and also is a research
scientist said to me,
you know what I decided just
to start my own company.
And I didn't just
start my own company,
I developed the relationship
with the funder.
I maintained that relationship
as my relationship
with the funder.
So that gave me power and power
was an operative word three.
So enough from me.
Let me introduce our
panel very briefly.
We're very, very fortunate
to have a very diverse panel
representing all the
different stakeholders just
like panel one did.
We have a policy expert,
a PhD biologist who's
a venture capitalist,
and then we
have Robin who is an academic.
So Victoria is the
founding executive director
of women and public policy
at the Harvard Kennedy
School of Government.
Their mission led by
Victoria is gender equality
to improve the lives of
women across the globe.
Ann is the senior
director of investments
at Sanofi-Genzyme BioVentures.
She has a PhD in
systems biology from MIT
and also did a post-doc.
And she also went to HBS.
Ann can speak to the
transition from PhD academia
and also to the role that
venture capital might play.
In particular corporate
venture capital,
because there are two breeds
in venture capitalists and Ann
represents the corporate
strategic venture capitalists,
who are somewhat
different in what
they look for than the
institutional venture
capitalists.
And then furthest away
from me is Robin Ely,
she's a professor of Business
Administration at the Harvard
Business School.
And I had to get over saying
I went to the business school.
And I got laughed at
a lot in California.
Professor Ely will be
presenting research
on how HBS is tackling
the issue of it's
not so previously, not so
hospitable culture for women.
And Dean Nohria has taken this
on as an initiative to make HBS
a more inclusive environment.
And this has been led by Robin.
So we really would like to hear
your views, Robin, on ideas.
We will then ask each panelist
to speak for 15 minutes
and express their views.
And then I will take
questions for 15 and then
after that it'll be your turn.
And please come up with
lots of good questions.
Victoria.
-Thank you so much.
So we've had a really robust
conversation this morning.
And our entire
conversation has really
focused on how do
we navigate systems.
At the women public
policy program,
we've been working
for nearly 20 years
not on measuring
where the gaps are.
Tho we certainly do
some of that work,
but how do we
identify and define
a replicable interventions
to close those gaps.
How do you determine what
the intervention will cost,
how effective it is, and
where can it be applied.
This is a panel about
solutions and we're
going to talk about
where is the edge of what
we know about how solutions
work and how to implement them.
My goal is over the
next 14 minutes,
I will give you some
things that you can
do within your organization.
Now because we can't
immediately fix all the systems,
having conversations
about how to navigate them
is extraordinarily important
and impactful and needed.
And we today are particularly
talking about gender,
but I think it's very
important to remember
that what we're
really talking about
is any non-traditional
actor in the system.
Anyone who breaks with the
stereotypical frame and I'll
talk about that and
specificity in a few moments.
So we had discussion in
the earlier panel about how
are women leaders perceived.
This is Heidi Roizen, CEO
formerly of a very significant
tech firm.
There is a case written
about her for HBS.
And some of Robin's
colleagues thought, you now
our students are reacting
to this case in such a way
that it really gives us pause.
And they decided to take
this case about Heidi
and substitute Howard for Heidi.
And very similar to what
Allison talked about where
nothing else changes.
And it's a beautiful
experiment, right?
Because we have students
that we can put in one place,
and students we
can put in another.
We can change it
over a time period,
but keep everything the same.
And what they found is when
the behaviors are identical,
people like Howard more.
They think Howard
is a better leader.
They think they learn
more from Howard.
And they want to work
with Howard more.
Now Kathy McGinn's
work, which was that
also focused on warmth
versus competence.
When Debra talked
about how people
are seen within organizations,
and when there's
lots and lots and
lots of women, it's
OK if there's some women who
are tough and hard and abrasive.
And it's OK if there
are some women who
are warm and friendly.
Assume both competent.
And they can be viewed
as competent and.
But what happens when you only
have a few, which is the way
most people read our
entire cultural narrative.
And let's talk about
predominantly in the west,
because that's where most
of these studies are from.
But the entire
cultural archetype
is that women are either
warm or competent.
Either beautiful or a
really good venture VC.
And part of what we
need to do is to create.
So system.
So right now we're talking
about the past as all them
and about how to
navigate the system.
Navigating the system,
again, very important.
But the future is about
designing systems such
that individuals don't
have to work so darn hard
to navigate them.
And so that organizations don't
have to constantly operate
in a system set, where they
are likely to produce sameness,
which means they're not
capturing the talent.
Several times it was mentioned
and I'm going to call it Debra,
again.
That this isn't a problem
about equality or diversity.
We could have a
conversation about equality
and that's a really
important conversation,
but I myself and the women in
public policy program for 20
years I have worked
on gender issues,
I work in the White House with
the Council on women and girls,
I work with the
State Department,
I work regularly with all
kinds of policy positions,
I share the commission on
the status of women and girls
here in the state
of Massachusetts.
All day I focus on how do we
take interventions and turn
them into policy.
I almost never talked
about equality.
When one is trying
to create change
and one has stakeholders,
it is very difficult
to convince your
stakeholders that you
should take your eye
off the ball for what
you're required to do.
Take your eye off performance
measures and outcomes
that you will need to
present and perform on.
Turn your time and attention
to an issue which may not
impact you in
direct ways that you
can understand to solve
a problem that I believe
is important that
isn't on your list.
Do we agreed that
sounds like a hard sell?
What is incredibly
strategically effective
for organizational change,
an organizational design,
is to understand what
is the main mission
of that organization.
What are the key problems
that they need to solve.
What interventions
do I have that
I can convey that a replicable
and ideally inexpensive that
can solve a problem that is on
someone's list to enable them
to reach their main mission.
And that is the future
organizational design
and closing gender gaps.
And I'm going to give
you a few examples today
and then I'm happy to take Q&A
about them or any other topics.
And we often draw upon
behavioral insights.
Now does anyone know
what that picture is of?
Someone said it.
Say it loud.
Nice work.
Petrified wood.
Now we talked today
about how few women
are at the top of that pyramid.
And everyone in their mind
can see that catalyst pyramid
with just a few
women at the C-suite.
And then the number
of women broadens out
as that pyramid goes down
into the lower levels.
One of the things
that we do when
we talk about how
bad it is-- and I've
been showing that pyramid
for years so I'm culpable.
I'm in the tank.
One of the things that we do
is we normalize behaviors.
Now I show you a piece of the
Petrified Forest, because years
ago they used to have signs up.
Has anyone actually been there?
OK.
You may recall it.
Signs that would say,
please stay on the path.
Do not go off the path and
put pieces of Petrified Forest
in your pocket.
Four tons of the
Petrified Forest
leaves every year in small
pieces that people gather.
Now what happened
with these signs
is that the number of tons
of missing Petrified Forest
did what?
-Went up.
-Increased.
-It rose, because they
literally gave us step
by step guide of how to take it.
And most importantly they
said, everyone is doing it.
And what we need to now do--
there is discussion about two
being the number on boards.
Another way of
looking at it, we can
say most boards have around
20 something, only two women
are on them.
Low number.
Negative story.
Or I should say
negative narrative.
Equally positive narrative,
equally accurate, more positive
narrative, excuse me, is to
identify that most companies,
depending on what
country you're looking
and 70% of countries,
80% of countries
have women on their boards.
The actors who are behaving
in ways that we do not
find desirable need
to be presented
as the outlier whenever
it is accurate.
So part of it is how do we tell
people what they should think.
People want to be in
the regular group.
We all like to think that we
want to be really special.
Our behavior does
not demonstrate that.
Our behavior demonstrates we
want to be like everybody else.
Now how do we get to
the good outcomes.
Old board room.
Wonderful study by one of our
former researchers at the women
and public policy
program, Aaron Dhir.
And what Aaron focused on
was where in the organization
do you want to put your
gender interventions.
And he looked at
how you may have
noticed on the back
of your perspectives,
or buried towards
the end, there'll
be a disclosure
about the diversity
policy for the
organization, but you
are being asked to
identify and vote
for who they put on the board.
As soon as an intervention
is about compliance,
not main mission, compliance,
no action follows from it.
What his study showed wasn't
that you had low effect,
you have zero
effect consistently.
Once something lands in
the OGC's office, and this
is something we have
to do, and it's not
about what we have to
provide to our stakeholders,
no change takes place.
And you can end
up with rooms that
look like that or your rooms
remain looking like that.
Now how is it that we
get to a very vastly
different situation.
Somebody earlier had talked
about what it's really about
is talent management.
And when our wonderful Dean
Cohen from the Radcliffe
Institute opened her remarks.
She talked about how the
education gap has reversed.
In the United
States and in Europe
and over the next several
years in South America,
the majority of those to
get high school, associates,
college, and postgraduate
degrees are all-female.
So what that means is the
talent force is female.
The larger the company and
the larger the government,
the more they're aware of this.
The larger the
government, the larger
the company, the more likely
they are to reach out to me
or one of my colleagues
to try to understand
how did they do it right in both
access talent pools in hire,
retain, and promote.
Recall and remember, women,
we are not an interest group.
When you look at
the talent market,
we are literally
the whole ball game.
So, what we see here
is an orchestra.
There's wonderful work done by
Claudia Goldin examining what
took place when all of a
sudden orchestral auditions
took place behind a screen.
I will summarize.
The number of women who are
selected in final rounds
went up to 30%.
And this is for a task
which everybody understands
all you want is to hear
the music, an incredibly
disassociated task in terms
of whether men or women could
do it better.
All you have to do is hear it.
Now we can't replicate
having a screen in every hire
that we do.
But several things take
place, one, hiring in bundles.
Those of us who are
here from industry
understand that initial classes
which come into organizations
tend to be more diverse.
But that diversity doesn't carry
forward as we move people up
in organizations.
Why?
If I ask you today
and I want each of you
to think you could have anything
you want for dessert at dinner.
Can you each think of it?
Janet, I'm going to pick on you.
What would you like for dessert?
Pecan pie.
If I ask you to fill out
a calendar for every lunch
and every dinner for
the next 12 months,
will you only choose pecan pie?
Of course not.
When people are
hiring in bundles
they understand
and have awareness
that they will want diversity.
But when people are
hiring for one offs,
they tend to want what
their favorite is.
Favorite is a
substitute word for what
Allison talked
about as well, which
is people want to hire for
what they view is male tasks.
What tasks are male and
female are defined by culture?
There is nothing
innate about them.
And we know this, because they
vary by culture, by region,
by time period, but we don't
like breaking that gender
stereotype.
So what we know-- moving
on to a terrific paper
by WaPPPs director, Iris
Bohnet and her colleagues,
Max Bazerman and
Alexander van Geen,
is that when we look at one off
hires and one off promotions,
the nontraditional
candidate does very poorly.
One offs are never measured
against another live person.
They're measured against
a fictitious norm.
It is really hard to
be the fictitious norm.
Really hard.
So what happens is when you
compare more than one candidate
and you can easily
build processes
within companies where you
look at multiple people
at a stage or time period.
And I say time period
because you can't always
make that higher promotion in
multiple departments at once,
but you can look back
over time to compare
against other former candidates.
And once you're looking at
real data, the effect of bias
goes away.
Then we begin to compare
Janet's performance
with Rebecca's performance, or
Janet's performance with John's
performance, and
women do very well
with no bias effect, which
by the way is a huge finding.
We would expect at most it would
be mitigated but not go away.
And I have lots of other
things I could go through,
but we're going to
skip all that and we're
going to jump to policy
making for a moment.
Big solutions require
systems design.
And I gave you a
couple examples of ways
you can redesign systems to
help people get over their bias.
Let me also note this is
not a guy-girl problem.
This is not something
that bad men do to women.
This is a problem that each of
us is pickled in the culture
that we live in.
It is very easy to put the
cucumber into the brine.
It is nearly impossible to get
the brine out of the pickle.
Men and women hiring
officers underpay women
at the same rate.
Female CEOs provide really
significant role modeling
effects.
Role modeling
effects dramatically
change the fictional
norm in one's mind.
It gets recreated.
And it gets recreated in
really spectacular ways,
which is why there's incredible
tools that can be used.
And you can find--
Oh, this is a
really great thing.
I'm out of time, but I'm going
to share it with you anyway.
As we talk about recreating
what things look like.
Now here's an ad.
I don't know if anyone actually
saw this ad in your journals,
but this is a woman
who's an engineer.
She was in this ad and got
really awful feedback--
Facebook, and
Twitter, and so forth.
And she started a hashtag
of I look like an engineer.
And all of these different women
have joined in and re-created
what it looks like.
And each of us keeps culture.
In each of us sits
in a position,
where we have the ability
to begin to change
organizational design.
There are some of us
who sit uniquely placed.
And I just want to share
as my final comment
with the audience, it
isn't enough to think
about what are the opportunities
for the change I can make,
it's about what are
the responsibilities
for the change I must make.
And identifying where you have
the power, and the impact,
and the ability, and then
who do you reach out to,
and how do you ensure
that you consistently
have the tools that you need.
Everything I've
talked about today
are the types of things
that I and my colleagues
go and talk to leaders about.
And we thought how do
we bring this to scale.
How do we turn this
from my conversation
that I'm having with Valerie
Jarrett and her key advisers,
or with the governor,
or my colleague
Iris Bohnet is having with
the [INAUDIBLE] administration
to something that anyone
can have access to
and any person in any
organization can do.
And we created what's called
the gender action portal.
All the research I
mentioned today and hundreds
of other studies, which are
all experimentally based,
they are not best practice,
they are not views,
they are experimentally
tested information--
are on the gender action portal.
Every paper is summarized
in lay person's terms
all the way down to one
sentence and then to one screen.
And you can link and see
where the study took place.
You can link to the--
for my colleagues
who'll want to read the
entire studies, soup to nuts
and understand all
the methodology.
There is a methodology
summary, but there is also--
you can go to the full paper.
But it provides tools
that you can use
and its all searchable
by general public topic
conversation topics.
Thank you very much
and I look forward
to hearing from the
rest of my co panelists
and from hearing
from your questions.
-Thank you, Victoria.
And I would like to invite
you to make your comments.
-Thanks.
It's an honor and
pleasure to be here today.
I've just been super excited
about the presentations
and the discussion
that we've had so far.
So I'm excited to
contribute my thoughts.
So to kick off I
thought I'd address
why developing the
strategies and solutions
is important in economic
terms from my perspective.
So as you may know
we're currently
living in the longest
open IPO biotech window.
I would have made the
same statement in February
and we are six months later.
The past three years have been
the biggest most lavish party.
The NASDAQ biotech index went
up 54% in 2013, 34% last year,
and hit 34% earlier this year.
In 2014 74 biopharmas
entered the public market
raising $5.6 billion.
As a level set, if we added up
all the IPOs from 2008 to 2011
for those four years, only
42 stocks of companies
went to the public market
raising only $3.6 billion.
For the first half
of 2015, we've
already had over 40 biopharmas
into the public market.
And they've raised $3.8 billion.
As a result of the
strong IPO market,
the venture capital firms who
invested in these companies
started making distributions
to their limited partners
and to themselves.
The reported gross IRR for
the biopharma venture industry
from 2011 to the first
quarter of this year
is 70% with realized
gross IRRs over 100%.
This in turn provided
venture investors
the ability to raise new funds.
And raise new funds that have.
In 2014 the biotech
venture community
raised over $9 billion.
As a level set, if you simply
look at 2013, the far more
usual $4 billion.
At the end of Q2 2015,
the venture community
had already raised almost
another $9 billion halfway
through the year.
And you might have
noticed [INAUDIBLE]
news yesterday announcing
a new $1 billion
fund in their SEC filing.
Furthermore, the
venture community
is deploying these funds.
2014 companies raised
$6 billion for venture.
The industry norm is usually
somewhere between $4 and $5
billion a year.
And as anticipated 2015 is
tracking to outpace 2014.
And in the first
half of 2014, company
has raised already $4
billion in venture.
Interestingly, the number of
new deals is holding steady.
So the size of the
deals are increasing.
So the wealth creation
and real distribution
over the past three years
has been tremendous.
So who is capturing the wealth?
Let's start with
the management team.
We've talked about this today.
So I'll just add my two cents.
If you look at the 30
biopharmas that entered the US
public markets in 2015 of the
set I looked at the other day,
one of the 30 had
a woman as the CEO.
Thinks to Jill
over at Catabasis.
If you look at the
CEOs of the 91 biotechs
who had venture financings
in 2015 so far, 11 of the 91
have women CEOs.
That's 12%.
And looking at the
boards-- here I
just looked at the private
companies in our portfolio.
And I was encouraged.
40% of the companies had
a woman on the board.
That's the marketing message.
-It's nicely stated.
-However, if I looked
at the number of women
board members relative to the
total number of board members,
6%.
So let's look at the investors.
And looking at the 40 firms that
raise new funds in 2014, 2015
located here in the US,
roughly a quarter of the funds
had women partners.
And looking deeper
at the early stage
active institutional
funds that I work with,
these 18 firms had 120
managing or general partners,
and 11 of them were women.
That's 9%.
So the wealth creation
story I've described
has been developing and
playing out over years.
It's real and material
the past three years.
And there are scarce
few women in this story,
but people are making money.
So let's move on to thinking
about creating strategy
and solutions for
increasing access
and likelihood of success.
So as we know Boston is the
dominant biotech cluster
in the world.
In large part because
of the meticulous,
well oiled innovation
system that we have.
The parts include entrepreneurs,
management teams, investors,
academicians, and others.
In increasing the
achievement of women in all
parts of this ecosystem is
critical to a robust net gain.
So I'll offer four areas to
consider for enacting change.
Where it all begins, recruiting,
marketing, and investing.
So area one, addressing where
it all begins, and here I
reference the work of
Nancy at MIT and others.
Nancy found that women faculty
participation and company
founding was about 5% relative
to their male colleagues.
From experience I
deeply know that
whoever the founding
academics are
deeply shapes what that company
will look like for its life.
The academic founders are
the number one employee
in the early stage biotech.
Their interests, their
vision their personality
and who they call--
the investors
the entrepreneurs-- is critical
to how the opportunity evolves.
So I would encourage the
continued work in that area.
Area two, recruiting, building
leadership and management teams
a pipeline for
success in biotech.
So here we've already
heard some thoughts
I think experience
credibility and network can
be built very effectively.
And some of the
larger organizations,
they may provide the
development opportunities
the experience set
importantly a place
where you can build your
network before moving
into what I'll call less
normalized environments
of early stage biotech.
I acknowledge the points on
the network versus hierarchy,
but I do think there
are a lot of benefits
to being in a large organization
with resources you can readily
harness.
Successfully transitioning
women from these institutions
into the early stage
innovation biotech ecosystem
as senior executives,
I think, is
something we need to work on.
Here I'll highlight
a group that I've
been involved with for many
years called, Springboard
Enterprises.
It's a nonprofit
organization that's
dedicated to supporting women
entrepreneurs in startup
executives.
They have excellent
mentorship, access
to an incredible network
of alumni and partners
and investors.
They built up almost
in two decades.
The level of experience
doesn't matter at Springboard.
The platform is open whether a
woman is on her third start up
or her first.
She has no years of
experience or she
has decades of experience.
The platform is
there to be used.
The third area that I offer
for enacting change-- marketing
successes and creating
new frameworks.
So I hope this is all very
much along the lines is
what's been discussed already.
The community needs to
market success stories
to expand the phenotypes
that fit success
in the minds of the investors
and of senior executives.
So the New England Venture
Capital Association, the NEVCA,
the regional venture
capital group.
The director, who just
recently left, CA Webb,
I thought made excellent
strides in the last five years
to help the New England
venture community market
its own successes.
And she paid
particular attention
to the success of women.
I'm very interested
in who's going
to be the new director of NEVCA,
because the success that I feel
CA has put in that organization
over the past five years
has been tremendous.
Area four is the
investing community.
Here I think we can take
advantage and continue
to foster the changing landscape
in the investment community.
So just a couple words on
the traditional institutional
venture capital community.
The industry knows
it has a problem.
And it's trying to take
some steps to address this.
But you can imagine
it's pretty hard
when you've been raking in
cash for the past three years.
So in 2011, back pre-boom,
the National Venture Capital
Association, the singular
venture capital industry
association of the US,
surveyed investors in the US.
And 89% of the investors
were male and 11% female,
as I think has been noted.
In 2014, the NVCA
took its first steps
and form the
diversity task force
on the lawn of the White House
and committed to developing
meaningful solutions to support
diversity in venture firms.
We'll see.
The first report this slated
for the annual meeting in 2016.
I think they have a
nice group of people
who are on that task force,
a combination of people
I think who can put forth some
really compelling suggestions
that I hope at least a
large chunk of venture firms
will be able to adopt and will
speak to their interests, which
let's be clear institutional
venture capital,
your job is to make money.
In the meantime, with
the boom that's happened
there has been a tremendous
growth in alternative financing
sources relative to the
traditional institutional
venture capital.
And I think you can
start to see this
as you see the migration of
the institutional venture firms
into pockets, where they used
to sort of loan everything that
came out of the universities.
It's a very
interesting migration
that's been happening
over the past three years.
Family offices, angel
investors, an angel groups
we're often the sort of the step
children of the industry back
in the day.
They're often retail
moguls, media moguls,
that's who sort of belonged,
because that's who had money.
With the boom, successful
biotech executives
are now part of those networks.
They do financings
for companies.
I think many people know that
some of the genzyme executives
are now the angel
funders of many biotechs
that have started in Boston.
So what's been
offered by the venture
firms is now resident in some
of these alternative financing
sources that is highly
sophisticated investors that
know the business,
have the networks,
and have capital that
make them successful.
Another source of
capital that used
to be the odd man out
in traditional venture
is the corporate
venture capital group.
Today nearly every major pharma
has a corporate venture team
doing direct investments
in companies.
Many of these teams know
and live the business,
because that's what they live.
They have the relevant networks
and they have the capital.
So just as a level
set, the R&D budget
of Sanofi on an annual
basis is $5 billion.
On a usual year
that's the amount
that's deployed into the
entirety of the biotech venture
capital industry.
So small changes in
pharma R&D allocations
can have major impact on
early stage biotech investing.
And as some of you may know the
intense hunger of the pharmas
for innovation,
and the recognition
that much more innovation
happens outside of your walls
than inside of your
company's walls
has already begun
to drive change.
So there are many other
new sources of capital
that are having major impact.
Some of you may have been
following the amazing work
of the Cystic Fibrosis
Foundation, MMRF, Michael J.
Fox Foundation, and
JDRF in contributing
these different
sources of capital
into early stage biotech.
So in closing, the
new world that's
been created during this
heyday of biotech, I think,
presents challenges as well
as incredible opportunity.
It's important to understand
the magnitude of how women have
participated so far in this
process of wealth creation
and distribution.
And the examples that I've
given of groups, associations,
springboard, the
NEVCA, all these groups
are working very hard
on the four dimensions
that I've outlined.
So what's left to
be done other than
these individual dimensions need
to continue to push forward.
I think similar to
what others have said,
it's the orchestration
of the ecosystem
to lead to a successful
business outcome
that we're still missing.
So to be clear, venture
capital is a club.
The founders, the investors,
the board, the CEOs,
they're very pre-set and
have longstanding decades
of history, because
you trust each other
that you're going to make
money at the end of the day.
So how can we create a new way
to orchestrate the ecosystem
to achieve a successful
business outcome
and support the value
proposition of why
these companies, these investor
groups need to look different.
I think we can do this
in two different ways.
How do we orchestrate--
as has been suggested
that the system level,
more the structural level--
in coordinating
changes and sharing
across these different
groups-- what's happening,
so that we can have
the impact together.
And then the other
level at which
we can orchestrate the
ecosystem is at the-- I
call it as we were
talking earlier, Deborah--
sort of the get it done level.
So the entrepreneurs,
the investors,
the founders, the academicians,
and the executives--
the guys get together and
talk about what it is they're
going to do.
Why don't the girls
get together and talk
about what they're going to
do for their new company.
And I say that in a sense of
not to the exclusion of any one
party, but this
is how it happens.
So I think we need
to recognize that.
It's been a successful
model and let's maybe
try to replicate that with a
slightly different combination
of people at the table.
So I hope this has given some
ideas of the value proposition
or the business outcome.
And I hope that we can
see some real change.
And maybe there's an
opportunity from this forum
to come together to push
forward on some of these ideas
for better orchestrating
our own ecosystem, which
in Boston if we make a
change the rest of the world
will notice.
-Thank you, Ann.
And I'm glad that
you're so upbeat.
And Robin, please.
-Sure.
Thank you.
Well, it's really a
pleasure to be here.
Thank you for
inviting me and it's
been really interesting to
hear all of the other speakers.
And I go to a lot
of these conferences
and I don't say
that at all of them.
So what I'd like
to talk about today
is just to give you a
little bit of background
on how I see the problems
with women's advancement.
Where are the barriers?
I'm going to talk a little bit
about the cultural context,
that is outside of the
organization, the culture
within which the
organization is situated.
And I'm going to talk about
how that culture seeps
into the organization
to create a context that
creates barriers for women.
And then I'm going to
talk about a case example.
So this is Harvard Business
School culture and community
initiative.
So we've been over this
ground a little bit,
but I thought I would
just summarize it.
I think it speaks to
some of the findings
that we heard about earlier.
So these are the kinds
of messages that we get,
men and women.
We associate leaders
with these kinds
of traits-- competitive,
assertive, decisive.
And we associate women
with a different set
of traits like warm,
nurturing, and communal.
And the clear problem
here is that there's
a disconnect for women and
leaders, but not so for men.
So you can just kind of
replace man and leader
and get pretty much
the same thing.
This is, I think, the
message in a nut shell.
I don't know if you can read it.
It says, but when a woman
has someone's head cut off
she's a bitch.
So I actually think that this
might be the bad ass woman
that we talked about earlier.
And I do think that in
reference to some of the things
that Allison reported that these
are the messages that women
are getting.
That if you take a
position of power
there will be some
negative consequences.
So it's not surprising
to me that she
would find what she finds.
And I would attribute it
to this cultural context.
Here's another
message that we get.
So the cultural ideal, if it's
not to be a woman in power,
it is a mother,
who quits her job.
I take this from the cover story
in 2003 of the New York Times.
Lisa Belkin wrote an article,
which put basically opting out
into our lexicon.
It really has caught on.
We did a survey of
Harvard Business School
alumni, a sample of
over 5,000 of them,
and gave them a bunch of
different possible reasons
for women's stalled advancement.
And this was the one that most
people agreed with, that women
prioritize family over work.
So 75% of our alumni believe
this, and 82% of women.
So women were actually
more likely to endorse this
as a barrier, a reason that
women are not making it.
And I always like
to point out when
I present this slide that
I really think everybody
prioritizes family over work.
I don't think this
is a women thing.
It's what does that
actually mean to people.
And to men, it very often
means being a breadwinner.
So he's going to
ratchet up at work.
And for a woman, it
means to be a caretaker.
So she's going to ratchet back.
So it's not about
prioritizing family over work.
It's about how the
culture describes
what that sort of tells us
what that actually means.
And it's very gendered.
OK, so that's the
larger cultural context.
Now I want to talk about
the organizational context.
We talk about gender
norms and practices.
So for many years we had just
basic good old fashioned sex
discrimination.
We still have some.
But we call that now first
generation gender bias.
Those are explicit
intentional forms
of discrimination and bias.
They're against the law,
and we don't see them
as often as we used to.
What we're really
seeing much more now
is what we call second
generation gender bias.
This is implicit bias,
it's unintentional.
And it basically
comes in from the fact
that most workplaces
were designed
to fit men's styles
and life situations.
The organizations are filled
with practices and policies
and norms that appear
gender neutral,
but that when they're
enacted actually
create different patterns of
experience for men and women.
And they add up these
sort of micro practices
and interactions.
And Laurel talked about the
interaction or situations
that women and men find
themselves in organizations
are quite different.
And that's what I'm
talking about here.
And those are the things that
impede women's advancement
or push them out altogether.
I should say I don't
have time, but I
have a lot of data
also to suggest just
on that point of
pushing women out.
Yes, women are pushed out
more likely than they opt out.
But they're actually not
opting out at the rate
that we might think they are.
So I can speak to
that later, but I
didn't have time to go into it.
So a little bit more about
organizational context
before I get into the
case just to give you
a sense of what I mean.
So I'm going to give
you some quotes.
These are things that I have
heard in the course of my work
or my colleagues have heard
in the course of their work
on gender issues with companies.
So here's a health care
company, and a woman says,
I sat in a performance
review and actually
counted the number of times
women were described as nice.
That was never a
point of discussion
about the men being reviewed.
OK, so this is the
manifestation of what
I was talking about earlier.
That the fact that woman
doesn't equal leader.
In a financial
management firm, as soon
as I started working
at home one day a week
my performance reviews
went down despite the fact
that my clients were happier
and I got more work done.
This is irrational, but
we see this kind of thing
happening all the time.
And it's a result of that other
piece about the cultural ideal
of who women are.
And once they go home,
once they have children,
they're seen as less
committed workers.
So there's research
on that as well.
Here's an accounting firm, in
year end evaluation sessions
a woman was found
a little bit short
and we can see how she
was going to get there.
A man was found a little
short, but we could figure out
how he was going to get there,
because he looks like me.
This is a man speaking.
And I knew what I look
like five years ago
and what I needed
to grow into this.
So this is the kind
of thing that happens,
because of the demographics
of organizations.
And another one from a
consulting firm, our job
posting seek for perfection.
Men who don't meet all the
qualifications apply anyway;
women hold back.
So this is an interesting
one, because in this company
we were talking
to them about how
this was a gendered
practice and problematic.
And they said, oh
gosh you're right,
you know what we should do?
We should tell the women
they should apply anyway.
You know they should just
inflate what they-- you
know like what the men do.
We were like, well you
know you could do that.
You can change the women,
like that's what we always
want to do is fix the women.
Or you could actually post a
job posting that was realistic.
Imagine that.
That's what I'm talking about
when I say that organizations
are gendered and in my emphasis
and that of my colleagues
is to actually change
those practices.
To just to kind of
highlight a few things here,
these are practices,
performance, reviews, year end
evaluation sessions,
job postings, and then
we see that there is a
disproportionately negative
effect that those
practices, which
would appear gender neutral
on their face, have on women.
OK, so remedies.
So we hear a lot about
unconscious bias training.
This is sort of the
darling right now.
I think in particular
in high tech.
Google's doing this, so
everybody else is doing it.
So increasing awareness of bias.
Reducing discrimination.
Of course instituting work
family accommodations.
We know that's a
double edged sword,
well mostly it's negative,
because it produces
a kind of flexibility stigma.
People who take them--
and it is mostly women--
end up being stigmatized, and
their careers are derailed
And then this is
an interesting one.
So somebody who
was at [INAUDIBLE]
was telling me about a
dinner that he went to.
Actually it was a dinner
that Sheryl Sandberg had.
And apparently it's quite
a competitive thing like,
who goes to whose
dinners and there's
only two or three and who shows
up at yours and blah blah blah.
So this person was saying, he
had gone to Sheryl Sandberg's
and was very pleased to see
there were all these CEOs
and it was attracting
a lot of attention.
That's great news, but the
thing that was problematic,
which he noticed was
that they were all
talking about this--
oh well, we know
how to solve this problem
now that we see it.
Of course we'll just address it,
so we'll set some benchmarks,
we'll set some metrics and
we'll hold people accountable,
and the problem's
going to go away.
So unfortunately, that's
not going to happen.
What worries me a
little bit, because I
don't know where
their energy is going
to go when they find out that
actually it's not that easy.
So the perspective
that we take is
that accelerating women's
advancement is deep
ongoing transformational work.
This is culture change
work and it's very hard.
So I'm going to
give you an example.
We're like about four
years in and I would say
we made a tiny bit of progress.
So I just want to start there.
This is not like a
huge success story.
I'm not going to claim
a lot of progress here,
but I do think that
we're on the right track.
And I think there's
something to learn from it.
So we call it the culture
and community initiative.
It really was generated
from faculty recognition
of this historical
gender grade gap.
Some of you may
have read about some
of this in The New York Times.
I'm going to try and
set the record straight,
because actually
what was reported
was not really accurate.
But at any rate, so there
was this gender grade gap.
We had it for years.
It was something that was
publicly doned, because we list
the students who receive the
Baker scholar award, which
is based on grades.
And you can always just count
the number of women in the list
and compare it to the proportion
of women in the class.
And what you'd find is that
women were underrepresented.
They were about half.
So the thing is it was
never publicly acknowledged.
And then there was a faculty
meeting a number of years
ago now, where one of
my women colleagues
stood up and pointed this out.
Of course we would always
be whispering about it
next to each other and talking
about it behind closed doors,
but it wasn't public.
I think it was very important
that she raised this,
she asked the question,
she put it on the agenda,
people got very
uncomfortable, nobody really
wanted to sort of
think about why
it might be that women
were getting lower grades,
because of course the
underlying belief from many,
many of my colleagues was that
they just weren't that good.
You know.
Well, diversity is
really important,
but you have to lower
standards to get women in here.
We have a forced
grade distribution
and somebody's got to be at
the bottom in every class.
And it's going to be the
ones who are less good;
it's going to be the women.
OK, so that was I
think the story out
there that was not
voiced so publicly.
But we also had a
disproportionate turnover
among women faculty.
There were a couple
of years where
we lost a lot of junior women.
And that was quite noticeable
and quite disturbing.
So in 2010, Dean Nitin
Nohria was appointed,
and when he was putting
his priorities together
for his administration, he
talked to every faculty member
and was very surprised at how
much these first two points
came up in the conversation.
So he made inclusion one of
the schools five priorities
and he came to me and asked me
if I would head an initiative.
And actually he asked me to
head-- he had in mind something
very similar to what
had been done at MIT,
and that we would
write a report,
we would take a
look at ourselves,
and we would make
this report public.
So we've done everything,
but make the report public.
It's still on the
table that we might,
but it hasn't happened yet.
So he created the
culture and community
initiative and a new
leadership position,
which he appointed me to.
So here's the mission
of that project.
So it's to cultivate
a culture in which
all members of our community
can thrive and reach
their full potential
for advancing
the mission of the school
without compromising
excellence.
And so all members of our
community, our faculty,
students, and
staff, and we define
culture in this--
actually this is
in the sociological
literature, sociologists
would recognize it.
It's basically the way
we do things around here.
And the underlying assumptions
of our approach, I think,
very similar to what
Victoria was saying
is that we really need to come
together around something that
lies at the core of what
the organization does
and what people are invested
in, the reason they're
in the organization
in the first place.
And that they actually want
to be held accountable for.
So it's really about mission and
purpose and gender disparities.
So the fact that we saw
these under representation
of women on our
faculty or in grades
that that's an indication
of broader system dynamics.
So those are
presenting problems,
but those are not
the problems that we
are oriented to solving.
We're actually oriented
to advancing something
that is larger and to
advance that we have
to address these other issues.
So I don't have time
to show you this video
that I just love of my dean.
If you just Google
W50 Dean Nohria,
it's the first two
minutes of the speech
that he gave at the close of
the summit that we had in 2013,
which was part of our
commemoration of 50
years since the admission
of women to Harvard Business
School.
And you'll see a person
who is demonstrating
incredible commitment
and passion
and I think that's
really important.
So let me just say a little
bit about these two projects
that we undertook.
There's a student culture
project and a faculty culture
project.
And Susan Sturm and Heidi
Brooks were our collaborators
with me on the faculty
culture project.
So I don't have a lot of time.
I'm going to go
quickly through this,
because I started with the
great gap that was public.
I want to address what
happened around that.
We did think about as we
undertook this project
and we were aware of
the gender grade gap.
It wasn't that we
were just focused
on-- our mission isn't
really to get good grades;
our mission is to
educate leaders who
make a difference in the world.
But we thought
maybe this grade gap
was an indication of
something else in our culture.
So this metaphor of
the canary in the coal
mine-- you send the
canary in, and if it dies,
there's something toxic
in the environment.
That was the kind of thing
that we were thinking about.
That's how we thought
about the grades.
So we investigated
the causes and I'm
very pleased to
say that after very
careful quantitative analysis
that was reviewed by just about
everyone who had an investment
in seeing the results one
way or another, showed that it
was not student qualifications.
So the gender coefficient
after we ran the regression,
adding in absolute
everything you could imagine
that we could control for.
Most people thought that that
gender coefficient would go
away once we put in GRE Quant.
By the way, GRE Verbal is more
highly correlated with it,
but it turns out
that that coefficient
went from here to here,
really didn't change at all.
And that really opened people's
eyes to the fact that gee,
maybe something was going on.
I think that was the
most important thing that
has come out of that project.
So in the course of this,
we raised awareness.
So there were a lot
of ongoing practices
that were designed to
increase effectiveness.
The New York Times article
talked about these practices
as if we had undertaken
them to close the grade gap.
That's not true.
We've had a grading tool
for a very long time.
We've had scribes in and
out of the classroom.
And we were undertaking
curricular innovations
as part of another of
the dean's priorities.
So if you haven't
read the article,
these are all the
kinds of things
that you could
imagine would help
to address potential faculty
bias in the classroom.
So what I think happened,
because these things had been--
it wasn't like there
was an intervention
and then things changed, these
things were always happening,
but I think that
they were now engaged
with a lot more
consciousness of gender.
And I think that's
an important lesson
that there has to really be an
intention around the practices
that get changed.
So one indicator of success
is yes, the grade gap
did diminish.
I think more
importantly, the students
are really now owning the
culture change process.
I'm going to have to go
through this very quickly.
So on the inquiry in the
faculty culture side,
rather than looking at
quantitative data that we had,
we hired an external team
that interviewed 120 faculty.
What I think is
important to note
about what we did with
respect to this project
as we started out by looking
at the culture of our school.
That was our real question.
How does HBS operate?
What are the cultural norms?
What are the practices?
Who's thriving?
Who's succeeding?
What does it take to thrive?
And what are the critical
junctures or turning
points in a person's career?
And what we know in
probably all organizations,
but in knowledge
work in particular--
so this is academia,
yes, but I think
there is a connection between
what happens at Harvard
Business School and
academia more generally,
and what happens
in industries that
are around knowledge work
professional service firms
and so forth.
So key experiences around
feedback and evaluation,
relationships are absolutely
crucial to advancing.
And so these were the
topics of these interviews.
It wasn't about what's
going on for women.
And by the way, we weren't
just focused on women.
It was a culture and
community project
so we were really looking
at any sort of groups
that were systematically
less able to thrive.
We conducted a
network survey, we
identify patterns,
and the different ways
that different groups
we're experiencing thriving
versus not thriving.
It was at that point that
we came in and looked
at race and gender and
other identity differences.
So the intervention,
the analysis
was conducted and conveyed
with an eye to action ability.
Just a quick example, one
thing that people have noticed
is that women tend to sit
on their working papers.
You can't get published if you
don't send the working paper
into a journal.
And so there was this like,
well women are sitting
on their working paper, so the
immediate interpretation is
well they lack confidence.
They don't want to send it out.
That's not so actionable.
What are we going
to do about that?
What was really important was
to say, well why are they not.
And then to get some sense of
well who are they talking to.
Well, actually a lot of them
are disconnected from faculty,
from senior faculty who can
help them shape their papers.
And help them figure out
when it's time to send it in.
And so we think that
maybe there was something
gendered like that going on.
We shared the full report
with the faculty, again.
It's a consciousness
raising story.
And what we've been
doing since then
is basically identifying what
we call high leverage task
domains, where we
can experiment.
OK, we've got this whole
story about our culture.
We see how it operates
differently, systematically
differently for different
groups including women,
but other groups as well.
So where are really
the pain points?
Nobody's going to undertake to
change a culture, especially
when-- by the way we love our
culture at Harvard Business
School, but we recognize
that there are some issues.
So it's really important
to identify where is it
that people have energy
for changing things.
And where is there actually
leadership in the organization
to take up some of
these experiments.
And so that's what
we've been doing.
I don't have time to speak
about some of the experiments
around developing
teaching skill.
It turns out that that's
a big leverage point.
It's a place where a
lot of people fall off,
both men and women.
But it might be
disproportionately women
for a variety of reasons.
And so experimenting
with different ways
of teaching people
how to teach and that
seems to be quite effective.
So I'm not going to be able
to-- I've gone way over.
So you can just read these.
And that's it.
Thank you very much.
-Thank you, Robin.
That was a very weighty
and meaty and content rich
presentation.
I don't know how
many of you know,
but the ambient
temperature in companies
was set for the comfort of the
man in the gray flannel suit
and it has not changed.
And also there's
data that suggests
that fathers are considered
more committed to their work
when they're fathers, rather
than when they're single.
Whereas mothers are
considered less committed,
which is interesting--
plays right
into the gender stereotypes.
But Robin, I would love to
continue your conversation
there.
Quick question is, you
mentioned that married women had
less of a grade gap than
unmarried women in class.
And I was married
when I was at HBS.
-You were safe.
-Yes, I was safe.
If you could give me a quick
answer on that and then
I have another question.
-Yeah, so we were having
just a sidebar conversation.
It wasn't something
I mentioned, but it's
true that in these
quantitative analyses
what we learned is that
there was no grade gap
and had not been between
married women and men.
And so when I saw that actually,
my immediate thought was OK,
so clearly it's the culture.
I mean like how can
you-- like what?
Married women are smarter?
I don't know.
It's interesting though
that some of my colleagues
actually looked
at that and said,
well it's obviously
not the culture.
Immediately had a very
different reaction to it
and believed that it was
because married women were more
committed than unmarried women.
So we actually took
a look at that.
And we compared married
and unmarried women,
and married and unmarried men.
The only thing we
really had access to,
which was how that might
indicate commitment
was how many hours
they spent studying,
which we asked them to report
at the end of each course
on average for that course.
And then we also
ask them how much
previous knowledge did you
have of the course so forth.
And we found that
actually women, all women
studied more than men.
But it wasn't just
the married women.
So single women were
actually-- it wasn't a lot,
it was something
like six minutes.
But was statistically
significant
that single women
were studying more
than men, which suggested
that that wasn't the problem.
So my sense is it has
something to do this competence
likeability trade off.
And also the fact that
I think that sexism
in our culture in
general, and not
going to be any different
at Harvard Business School,
it's going to be
more likely to be
directed toward young single
women and young married women.
And I think those are
the kinds of environments
that make it hard to
actually thrive and reach
your potential.
So I think that that
would be my explanation.
-Very interesting.
So as you mentioned,
HBS is the school
that's closest to industry.
And are there any plans to
take this wonderful research,
because the phrase I
always heard is we're
training the titans of industry.
So is there any
plan to take what
you've learned within HBS
with the baby titans in there,
to take it out to the
big grownup titans
and have them also
learn and change
from what you have discovered.
-Yeah, so I even though this is
one of my administrative roles
at the school now is the
senior associate dean
for culture and community
working on this project,
but I think of it
as my research.
It actually makes me feel
better that I'm doing research
when I'm doing it.
But to me it is, if it's
action research it's something
that Susan Sturm and I are
planning to write about.
I shouldn't say that so
loud, because it's upsetting
to some of my colleagues.
We are hoping to and as I
said it's still on the table.
So we are beginning
to talk about it.
I have talked to companies.
And I would love as part
of the gender initiative
that we've started- that's
a research initiative,
it's a outward
facing, it has nothing
to do with the internal
dynamics of our school.
But to use that as an
opportunity to link up
with companies to work with
them around some of the things
that we've learned
and perhaps maybe
even in the form of
executive education,
but also action research
in their companies.
So that's the idea.
-Great.
Thank you.
Ann, do you think that
biotech needs a rallying cry
around a lean-in, sort of
a Sheryl Sandberg approach?
Do you think that we are also
not utilizing social media,
because that's not
our business, we're
tech companies are very much
and imbued with the importance
of social media.
Should we be taking a
leaf out of their books
and using social
media to mobilize,
to bring up the problems,
because it really
stays within biotech.
It hasn't permeated
the way that everybody
knows a problem in tech.
So are these some of the
things that might help?
-So on the rallying cry, I think
with the more recent movements
that I had mentioned,
I do think there's
a building swell around that.
But in absence of tying it as
we've noted to the business
outcome or some specific
sets of data that indicates
to your stakeholders why
it is you need to do this,
I think it will fall
and will fall flat.
So I think a cry that
is educated by examples
of improved business outcomes,
I think, could be very powerful,
but in that context.
On the social media front,
I'm sort of two minds.
And in one sense I
don't necessarily
think that the addition
of social media
will profoundly
impact the problem.
I think primarily in
my view of the biotech,
where I operate in the
biotech world, which
is this early stage
little animal,
everyone kind of
knows everybody.
So I'm not sure what the
addition of social media
would be, because it's such
a relatively small club.
So I say that
acknowledging that we
want to try to bring
new participants in
and especially, I think there's
the additional consideration
of the numbers of
people and certain age
groups within the
United States and what
the demographics and
population of the US look like.
And I think getting
younger people involved
in biotech, who may not
be the CEOs at the stage
that they're at.
I think using social
media to attract them,
and again, on the line
of recruitment pipeline
and providing appropriate
sort of mentorship,
role models, marketing, I think
on that line it could be used.
But I'm not enough of a social
media or marketing person
to really comment.
-So I'm going to
push you on that,
and maybe it's just
my West Coast bias.
But the small club, which I
know well and I'm part of-- yes,
they know it and not highly
motivated do a whole lot.
But I think when it comes
under the bright light
of other people who are not
insiders, but are actually
critical it might have
some kind of impact,
and more importantly for
institutional venture
funds, who have to
go to institutions
to raise money unlike the luxury
of a corporate venture fund.
I think there to having--
because it's an ecosystem.
I think bringing that more
attention might do something.
So perhaps you
should do a lean in
or a biotech version of
whatever the right analogy is.
-Very fair.
-Victoria, we've all talked
about the business case
and it's clear that
the business case
has to be there when you're
talking about industry,
because policy
alone will not fly.
Could you describe
to us what data
you use to make
the business case?
I've seen the publication on
the number of women on boards
becoming-- that's
just one study though.
It's the one that I hear
over and over again.
Is there enough
of a body of data
that you can muster to make
your business case compelling?
-It's a really good question.
So two things.
And before I talk specifically
about the business case,
I wanted to circle back
to one of the discussions
that we've had having to do with
navigating the system, which
is another way of
saying fixing the women.
And when we talk about
women not asking,
or women tilting their heads,
or women diminishing self
when they present--
women do this
not because they
lack confidence,
but because they're
effective tools
for navigating a
culture with incredibly
high social repercussion.
And our studies really show
that when women negotiate
that first job offer--
even if successful,
they are viewed as something
that rhymes with itch.
And it's not just a view, it's
actioned in the corporation.
People don't want
to work with them.
Whereas, when a man
negotiates the first offer,
it doesn't in any way conflict
with the cultural stereotype
of him being a good man.
Now, some of my colleagues,
like Hannah Riley Bowles,
again, looked at what Robin
highlighted, which is the why.
So what we find is that
if we have a conversation,
and if I'm talking to Anula,
and she's the hiring manager,
and I use a script that
is highly relational,
I diminish the backlash affect.
If I said, Anula, thank
you so much for that offer,
I'm incredibly looking forward
to working together and being
on your team, do you think
we could work together,
I know from looking
at other industry
reports and my background that
10% higher than that offer
would seem appropriate.
Could we do that together?
I'm not saying that's a
script one should need,
but it is a script
which is effective,
even for those of us who would
say, Anula, I can't imagine
working with a woman
who's more high powered
and effective in the field--
looking forward to it,
I'm worth more.
But that script, not helpful.
Anti female in terms of how
it lives in people's minds.
So I just want us to
be conscious in all
of our conversation
that patterns
you see women replicating
are there for reasons.
And when you're going
to change that pattern
you really better
understand what
is the unintended
consequence of that change,
and why have those
patterns been developed,
whether that's broadly
within the culture
or specifically in
your organization.
If you see women leaving
at a particular point,
you need to do some good
research to understand
what's going on at that point.
And the whole discussion
about opt out; what we know
is women who leave those high
powered positions are not
out for more than two
years at the very outset.
They go back in, so we're
not seeing an opt out.
What we're seeing is
a push out and a this
isn't working for me.
And that's about systems
design and the losers
aren't only women who
are underemployed;
the loser's the firm that
invested their time, talent,
and money.
So your question about
the business case-- so
the business case we have
mixed data on women on boards.
We have very clear
data-- think Scott Page
University of
Michigan-- indicating
that when you have
complex problems to solve,
diversity enables you to do
much better outcome production.
You have a complex problem--
diversity of field,
diversity of experience,
diversity of talent, culture,
you name it.
Much more effective.
Now when we talk
about a business case,
the majority of consumers
and consumer decision
making even on things
that are thought
of as male oriented tasks,
like purchasing cars, female.
When we think about who
is in the control seat--
largest growing market
in the United States,
does anyone know what
the demographic is?
Shout it out, guys.
Not just women, Latina.
Every city in the United
States, if it isn't already,
in the next 10 to 15 years
will be majority minority.
When you talk about
wanting to sell a product
or service in the United
States, if you do not understand
who the United States
is your business
is very unlikely to succeed.
When we had the opening
discussion and Dan talked
about the experience
at the FDA, that
is the experience of
what talent in America
is going to look like.
Now note there's some
huge downsides to that.
It is a crisis that boys are
being under-served in school.
It's not my area of expertise,
it's not something I focus on.
There are people who
are focused on this.
This is an enormous problem.
And if you think of how
dynamics have played out
in particular communities,
where you have females who
are much more highly educated,
who have much higher income
levels, have much
greater social mobility--
the African American community
in the United States.
And now all of those issues,
which people inappropriately
view as focus on that
ethnicity, they're
focused on what
opportunities are.
And where the
gatekeepers have been
and now math that more broadly.
These are very serious issues
that have to be addressed.
However, where we are today
having our conversation
about gender and
biotech, when we
look at what the
business case is,
the talent management
case is very clear.
The market share
case is very clear
and the efficiency
case is very clear.
It is expensive to have
talent that you've already
purchased and invested in and
they're not fully utilized.
You had talked about Amy
Cuddy's work on motherhood.
This is a perfect example.
And we've had a
lot of discussion
about women's behavioral
choices-- two steps back.
These aren't choices.
If I give you a menu with
four things on it and I say,
you're welcome to
eat any of these
for the rest of your life.
You would not feel
that you made choices.
You would feel
you selected among
a constrained environment.
The way most workplaces
look in the United States
for most employees,
they're selecting
among constrained environments.
We're the only
country in the world
that has no mandatory
form of paid leave.
Workers are not guaranteed
by statute a single day
of sick leave.
Our structural set up
creates an inefficiency
within our talent market.
So we could go on, but
that gives you the--
-So may I ask you, Robin,
do you buy the idea
that Victoria brought up, women
are the biggest decision makers
in health care?
They research the web more
than four times as much as men
to get information.
They make decisions,
they hold the purse,
and they also take care of
their kids, and they're parents.
So they are making the
majority of decisions.
Why has that not become
a compelling business
case for companies
in life sciences
to look at that as
a target market?
-I don't really know.
I think there's all
the things that we've
been talking about in the first
panel and the second panel.
A lot of it is irrational.
To hold gender stereotypes
in the face of reality
is irrational.
So I mean that's a
longer conversation.
What is the unconscious
dynamic going on?
Why are people so
invested in believing
that gender stereotypes are
true when there's unbelievably
little evidence to support it?
I guess that's what I would--
-Thank you.
I'm way over time on the panel.
May I now invite the audience
to pose questions to the panel.
So please come up
to the microphone
and identify yourselves
and your affiliation.
Thank you.
And also feel free to identify
the panelists to whom you'd
like to address your question.
Go ahead.
-Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm actually a senior here at
Harvard studying economics.
Thank you all for coming
here and speaking to us.
I was wondering what do you
think is the most important
for women, who are especially
in the early stages
of their career to know.
And what do you
think women can do
to ensure that they're
getting enough guidance
and mentorship, especially
given that a lot of this people
in senior positions our men.
-OK.
So four quick things.
One, when you seek out networks
and mentors and sponsors
you need to find people who
don't just look like you.
Women tend to
benchmark and level
set against other people
who are like them.
Everybody does it.
But you don't want to put
yourself in a position
where you're not getting
information from people who may
have more access to networks.
Two, your job at
this stage of life
is to make choices that
give you as many open doors
in the future as possible.
So even among
specializing you want
to make choices that give
you more choices ahead.
Three, listen,
collect information,
however, trust your
own instincts and gut.
Don't let anybody
tell you otherwise.
You are the only person
who's the CEO of your life.
Admire and respect yourself.
And figure out what do you
want to do and pursue it
tenaciously.
And lastly, really look at
different industries and then
different organizations
and see how people who do
look like you fair there.
Don't be deterred,
but understand
what choices you're making
and the amount of tenacity
and rallying and
resources it may
take to achieve there so
that you are ready to do it.
-I have been a bad moderator
in that I've exceeded time.
So, therefore, could everybody
please ask one quick question.
And could the answers also
be fast; this is my request.
Go ahead.
-OK, I'm going to try.
I'm Lauren [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a postdoc in systems
biology at Harvard.
And my question is
kind of prompted
by Ann's discussion of the
market value of biotech
recently and that these
people are raking in the cash.
I was thinking is this the
value we need or want to promote
and will women in leadership
help us reassess this value.
Because women are like
the traditionally the
subjugated class and are subject
to the consequences of power.
So it's kind of question.
-Ann.
-Wow, I feel like I'm
loaded either way.
OK, so I think I'll
answer it this way.
People will come to
me and say, how do you
get a job in venture?
Really love technology, I love
science, I could sit all day
and find like compelling stuff.
That's great.
And then I have
to break it them.
If you're looking for a job
in institutional venture, what
happens is you need to get
someone to write you a check
and you need to hand them
cash back preferably much,
much more than
what they gave you.
And stop.
There are some constraints
that LPs may put on funds,
but by and large,
that's the profession.
So we'll separate that out.
If you look at the pharma
and biotech industry,
what are they in the
business of doing?
Well, they need to generate
profit and revenue, but the way
that they do that is by
making products ideally
that transform patients' lives.
So depending on
sort of where you
are in the context
of that organization,
I think the Genzyme is
a prime example of this;
it was and even
the Sanofi CEO, who
just started about 120 days ago,
his first town hall at Genzyem,
the Sanofi CEO said to
the Genzyme leadership,
you are a mission
driven organization
that is very different
than what I have
seen in other parts of Sanofi.
And the mission is
patients' lives.
So I think depending on where
you go in the ecosystem,
you can readily understand what
is the business outcome they're
trying to achieve.
And what are the tools
available to them to get there.
I think that might
help in making choices.
-Thank you.
I have a question
for the organizers.
I just want to know
whether we can accommodate
the long line that's
forming there, because if I
do any math whatsoever.
It's not working out.
OK, so we would please ask
no one else to join the line,
but we will be delighted
to accommodate everybody
who's already up there.
Please go ahead.
-Hello, my name is Daisy.
I am just defended my PhD
at MIT couple of months ago.
My question kind
of relates to what
we heard in the
first panel, which
is that women, the matter
of their attractiveness
are less likely to get funding
for their entrepreneurial goals
than attractive men overall.
So we have a lot of information
about the overall big picture,
what we can do to improve
things in the long term.
But more immediately, what
can female entrepreneurs
do to get their odds to
the same level as men.
Do you just have to be
better no matter what?
Or can you actually
just get an idea
that's as good as somebody else
and actually have a chance.
-Ann.
-So I will lead, but I will
defer to my other colleagues
to provide me data support.
But I think the evidence
is by and large, you
do have to be better.
So you've got a bigger job.
I'd say from an
investment perspective,
if the question is around
approaching investors,
it's a relatively small set
of people who are investors.
You can usually get to know what
it is that investor's about,
for example, find out who
else they have invested in.
And I would talk
with those people
in whom they've
invested to figure out
what is that person about.
Because if you take
money from someone,
if you're sort of getting
married, because at some point
money will go back and
you're now in a long term--
if it's venture, you're in at
least sort of a 10 year fund
relationship around that money.
And ideally those do become
marriages with the wedding day
on the day the financing closes.
So I think really
understanding those investors
that you want to
approach and who
you would contemplate
taking their money,
I think is an important element.
And understanding, I think,
it's relevant to look
in their portfolios to see
if they have ever invested
in a management team that looks
like a team that you think
might be reflective of
what you want to build.
-Thank you.
-That was great advice.
-Hi, my name is Jen [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a postdoc at the
Center for Integration
of Science and Industry
at Bentley University.
And my question goes
to what Victoria
was talking about with framing.
And how do we go from
the large tendency
to highlight research
noting gender inequality
to the research that highlights
the benefits of gender
diversity.
And what can we do to promote
that feeling in the same way
that corporate social
responsibility standards helped
improve sustainability
views in industry?
-Great question.
A few things are coming.
I mean, one, if you look
across-- thinking about boards,
if one looks across Europe
and the rest of the world,
the reality is there's
a huge regulatory frame,
and it's coming.
Most of the major
multinationals-- everyone's
got a foothold everywhere.
Impact and pressures there
are going to resonate.
What we're also saying
and I had participated
in some of the architecture
around is really
looking at federal contracting.
So long story short, you're
not out there all alone.
And more is going
to come and it's
about really knowing the
research well, and discussing
all the facets of it.
And holding your institutions
accountable, realistically.
You are not the only
female scientist
currently in your field
that your program, correct?
-No.
-Have as many allies and don't
presume men won't be allies.
Ask for things and frames,
which aren't only around gender.
Thank the heck out of people
when you get what you want,
and expect it.
And expected it.
And choose wisely,
which battles you fight.
You do not fight
battles, in my view,
when you're
negotiating for a job.
You fight battles that you can
win then for what you need.
And then once you're
inside you work on.
There are times
to be rebellious,
and rebellious is not when
you're negotiating yourself,
right?
That's a time when you
want an external validator.
-Thank you.
-Hi, my name is
Amanda [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a grad student at MIT
in computational biology.
Thank you to all
the speakers today.
We've heard multiple
times today about how
women experience marriage
and motherhood differently
than men in the workplace.
And I've seen a lot of data
recently about millennials
and younger generations
are ranking this as a lot
less important to
them for their future.
So my question is, what
is a situation currently
for women who were unmarried
or don't have kids?
And how do you think
that will change
as that demographic grows?
-Do you have any
data on this topic?
-Well, I thought you were
going to go someplace else.
What I've seen, first of all,
is that companies are not--
they're not oriented to
recognizing or supporting
men's very strong commitments
to actually being caretakers
and not just breadwinners.
So I just want to say that,
I think if you actually
look at what people's experience
is, men are having a very
hard time, not just
millennials are having
a very hard time managing
the requirements meant
for professionals that
they be available 24/7.
I think what I've
seen in my research
on this among single
women is that it's
almost as if the
organization is sort of set
up almost not to recognize the
possibility of single women
or women without children.
And so women do--
they do it's just
kind of get grouped together.
It's sort of like
that's who women are.
They're understood
as someone who
will be either is a mother and
that means a certain thing,
or who will and wants to
be and will be a mother.
But your question was, what
do you do about that, right?
Yeah.
-I have an answer to that.
-Great.
-If you want.
-I was about to come up with
something, but go ahead.
-OK, no, no.
And if you have come up with
something, interrupt me.
-Yeah, I'll keep that--
-Completely.
So one, what we know is
narrative is really powerful.
And there's going to
be a narrative, which
is laid on you, which
is probably inaccurate.
And I love the way Robin
refers to it is irrational,
because it is.
So what you have to do is
understand the narrative,
which is laid on you.
And the narrative is if you have
a child, even if your behaviors
change in no way, you are
viewed as less committed,
less engaged, your pathway to
promotion virtually disappears.
And the guy down the
hall does better.
But once you know that,
then you know what to do.
And the way you
inoculate yourself
from that is when
you're on leave
you have touch points
with your manager.
When you return you go in front
of them and you say, I'm here,
I'm looking, what's my
next stretch assignment,
which teams am I going to be
on, which programs, projects
am I running?
And you define it.
Now people will presume
whenever they can't see you
that you're with your child.
It's bananas, but that's
what they presume.
So you have to have
a narrative where you
create an open schedule, right?
You paste it on your door.
You tell your colleagues,
I'm going down
the hall to negotiate a deal.
You have to be explicit.
And much of what this work
is when you understand
the cultural archetype
that's pasted on you,
you have to do the
work of peeling it off.
You have to tell
people who you are.
I'm organizationally committed.
I love being here till
9 o'clock at night.
And to do it authentically.
That's the other thing I'll say.
This is not a game
of showmanship.
This is a game of authentically
presenting and letting
people see you.
-Robin, do you have
a quick comment?
-Well, I guess I understood
the question-- maybe,
maybe I misunderstood.
I thought you were saying
that as a single woman what--
and yeah and not necessarily
anticipating that you're
going to be in that category.
But right now you
don't have the child.
You don't have and
yet you're going
to be perceived as someone who
is going to go down that path.
So how do you deal with that.
I mean, in some ways I would say
something similar to Victoria
said, which is, I think you
got to resist the pressure.
I mean, be aware that that
is a stereotype that's
going to be put on you.
And I think, creating your own
story and telling that story.
I guess what I would be
concerned about is I see that
there can be a kind of
a division among women
in the work place-- between
women who have children
and women who don't.
And so I would just
maybe want to say,
you know women find themselves
in different situations
for all kinds of reasons.
Having or not having
children is one.
Being partnered and partnered in
different ways is another one.
But I think it's really
important to-- even
while you're differentiating
yourself and saying,
this is who I am, these
are my commitments,
this is what I'm willing
to do-- to not lose
the connection to women who
are doing something different.
-Thank you.
-Nancy.
-Hi, I'm Nancy Hopkins.
I'm a retired professor
of biology from MIT.
And I'd like to thank
the Radcliffe Institute
for doing this
fantastic symposium,
the wonderful panelists.
I was totally depressed to hear
how much money women aren't
raking in.
-Me, too.
-Really sad.
But I'm even sadder,
actually, about the impact
this has within the
universities on the women
who were interested
in biology, including
having really brilliant young
women literally break down
in your office and say the
men go off into their office
with the young men in
their labs and talk
about the biotech
companies and leave
the women sitting outside.
So we've talked about how
the women should change,
and we've talked about what
the companies might do,
so I'd like to ask anyone
who's willing to answer it
what should the universities do?
What is the responsibility?
It's not an accident that
this industry has grown up
around these universities.
Same for Stanford.
And so, in a sense, I feel that
there's some responsibility
there.
Wonder what you
think about that.
How they could step in
to fix this problem.
-I'll just give you
one example that I
thought was very compelling
that came from Berkeley.
And Berkeley is not
looking at gender,
but is looking at the
reality that they're
aren't postdoc positions
and faculty positions.
And they have started
having symposia
on campus very frequently for
their postdocs and PhD Students
to meet industry and
venture capitalist.
-I think when it comes
to intellectual property,
each discipline define--
its very fascinating.
You know what you do as
an engineer the university
owns forever.
What you do and
things-- you know,
like anything having
to do with biomedical,
it appears that one
can take it with you.
I don't know enough about how
the OGC manages or does this,
but my thought is--
what would it take?
I think we all understand that.
It would take the
senior tenured faculty
to put enormous pressure
having-- I'm so aware now
that we're cameraed.
You know, conversation
you know thoughtfully,
with the corporation
about what this looks like
and what it means, I'm
fascinated by your thought
about Title IX and Title VII.
And I think that
is really Title IX
and Title VII are being looked
at and actioned right now
in a way they haven't
done before that there's
all kinds of growing
efficacy there.
-And do you think that there
should be a regulation applied
to the space?
Is that a good way to
deal with the problem?
-The problem is real.
-I think I'll make
an observation.
So someone's got to
take out the license.
So it's either
the entrepreneur--
these days in Boston a
lot of the venture firms
are engaged in the
early stage formation,
and the venture firms
are the ones who
take out the license
from the university.
I wonder what would happen if
the simple question were asked,
can you describe for me the
composition on the diversity
basis of your
venture firm or who's
going to be responsible for
developing whatever you're
licensing out?
Because we have
data in we believe
that you're more
likely to be successful
if you have a diverse team.
So I'm not sure about
from a policy standpoint,
but I think the
venture firms that I
know in town-- one
of the venture firms,
actually, on their website.
It was great.
I haven't looked
at it in a while,
because I don't look
at, because I know them.
And I was surprised to see
that there are a bunch of women
on the website.
And I was like what?
Who are these people?
I have never encountered
them when I see these guys
on like multiple times a basis.
And they had actually
put up all their admins.
Anyway, sorry
sidebar and perhaps
I should have turned
off my microphone.
-That is actually a very
common practice in VC firm--
-Should have turned off my
microphone for that one,
but I can't imagine what
would that conversation
look like even if it wasn't a
policy if the simple question
we're asked, can you tell me
about the diversity of the team
that's responsible for
making good on the license
I'm about to give you.
Because we have
data and we believe
it's more likely
to be successful
if you have a diverse group.
That's where I might just
start the conversation,
because someone might
just take notice.
-Thank you, Ann.
It's good answer.
-Great.
Thank you all so much.
My name's Theresa Nelson.
I'm a professor in the School
of Management at Simmons College
and really glad to be here.
I'm going to sort of
resonate to Ann's point
about the strength
of biotech in Boston.
And what an important factor
it is that we are here
and this is happening right
here as a world standard.
And also referring to
her comment about the
get it done, because
there's a group
of people here across
the ecosystem in academia
and entrepreneurs and
venture capitalists, who
would like to take some
action around this topic.
And we've been talking about
it for about two years.
And what we've
come up with we're
going to begin to actualize,
I believe, in the spring.
And would love to get
people's senses of it.
And it really has to do
with understanding the fact
that the pipeline as
Nancy said in biology
and academic medicine,
is so strong with women.
What an enormous
achievement this
is compared to 20
and 25 years ago,
referring to
Victoria's comments.
And we have been
wondering whether women
in the early stages of their
PhDs as well as PhD students,
postdocs, and those in
early science careers
are really aware of their
career options in terms
of commercialization; in
terms of the protection
of their intellectual property;
in terms of licensing.
Where is the expert in that
for them to reach out to?
And to really
understand that they
have choices to make
around commercialization.
So we're imagining
this has to be
something that happens
outside of the major teaching
institutions.
Perhaps and that this is a way
to really start a question so
that women in science have
enough of the business
entrepreneurship side as well.
And so I just love to get
your thoughts on that.
-Theresa, are you going to be
around for a glass of wine?
-OK.
Thank you for your patience.
This is the last question.
Yes, I was acknowledging
you and saying,
thank you for your patience.
-OK.
I'm Cassandra Smith.
This morning, I
don't remember who
said it, but alluded
to the fact that women
have more choices than men.
But they were referring
to children not to adults.
And my observation
is actually women
have a much narrower
cone of acceptability
in behavior than men.
And in fact, again,
it's my observations
that women are-- if they
kind of step out of this--
are much more subjected to
criticism or corrections.
And I think that's
what influences women
from speaking for instance
at faculty meetings
or at meetings like this.
So any comments.
Because the only comments
thus far in the meeting
were on young children.
That women, females, girls
have more choices than boys.
-I think it's actually
true for adults, too.
But it's a little
bit complicated.
I think the research suggests
that men will be punished more
for violating the
masculine stereotype
and evidencing
feminine behavior.
And women are punished less.
They're punished, but it is
more of a violation for men
to go in that direction.
So I think that's true
of adults as well.
I think what you're
probably noticing is
that the domains within
which women are circumscribed
are these public ones.
And so we see it and
that's what we're all here
being concerned about.
But I think if you looked
at men's violations
in the other direction, it's
just doesn't tend to be public.
And when it is public, it's
pretty severely punished.
And there's a lot of man
on man sexual harassment
and violations of
gender roles-- those
are the people who end
up getting sexually
harassed, both men and women.
But I think it's
not just children.
But that's my--
-Thank you, Robin.
We are 15 minutes over
so we really must stop.
And Janet, please.
-I'll just--
-Thank you, let me just thank
the panel and Janet will--
and thank the
audience, thank you
audience for hanging
in there for so long.
And Janet, please.
-I want to thank you all, thank
the panel, and the earlier
panel.
This is an incredibly
interesting day,
even if you're not in biotech.
I think you can really
see the biotech leadership
and the biotech board.
It's something of a litmus
test where gender relations
stand in our society.
This is an industry that
is less than 50 years old.
And you could argue
that it's leaders
are of an age where they
should know better than this.
And yet, it is one of the
biggest, most lavish boys clubs
we have around.
So I am glad on many levels
that we've come here together
to talk about it.
Today we've highlighted
the bias, the gender bias,
the irrational, the
implicit bias that
underlies much of that.
I'm very grateful for
Allison's data, which
are profoundly disturbing
is still validating
because it really reflects what
many of us still do experience.
We've also talked about
the internal conflicts
that women highlight and site.
Family is priority
in that conflict.
We talked a bit about
pulling way back
and seeing that not
necessarily as simply
the choices of individual
women but as systems problems.
You'll remember the phrase
the personal is political.
The personal is corporate.
These are systems
design problems.
We've also highlighted
some of the behaviors that
might be necessary
for women success--
demanding, giving time,
perhaps volunteering,
tilting your head,
and also the conflict
between what may be the
behaviors and the affect
needed for survival versus
that which is ultimately
needed for success.
I think this adds up to
the danger of almost a John
Henryism.
Those of you who
are sociologists
will recognize that term.
It was coined by Sherman
James to describe the attitude
among some minority
citizens that they
have to work harder to
get to the same place
the majority citizens do.
Even if it comes at a
cost to their health.
The reference is to
a tail, a folktale
about an African American
railroad man, a steel driver,
who vowed that he could beat the
steam engine with his muscles
and with his hammer to drive
a tunnel through a mountain.
And he went up against the
steam engine and dammit he won,
but he died with a
hammer in his hand.
I would say that the modern
day equivalent is that bad ass
woman who's working two shifts.
She's working all day
at the biotech firm
and she's going home to
work with her family.
She may get to that
C-suite but she's
got a briefcase on one
shoulder and a diaper bag
on the other shoulder.
It describes the
way it is, but it
doesn't have to describe
the way it should be.
I think we've talked
about making changes.
It isn't just about navigating
the system or fixing the women,
but really about
changing the system.
We've talked about really
making clear the value
proposition of having
women who stay,
inviting women in
having them stay.
The burden of proof,
unfortunately, I
think is on us.
We're the minority
in the situation,
we need to make that case,
we need to make it clearly.
We've talked about
change we must make.
We've talked about how that is
deep, ongoing, transformational
work to use Robin's phrase.
And we need to define what
is actionable change that we
can demand.
I'll just finish by
saying at the break I need
to draft these remarks so I went
out back in the hallway there
and a young woman
who I couldn't see
was out there too
clearly calling
her partner about-- looks
like this conference is
going to go long, can you
pick Alexandra up at daycare.
I didn't see you, I don't
know if you're here.
-That was me.
-Oh, that was you?
I was going to say as
I hope whoever you are,
you're still here,
because we need you.
We need every one of you,
we need you and your talent.
So thank you for being here.